happy monday everyone yes i'm back from
a long vacation you can't even see the
stitches
but i look pretty great this is how i
look before i left
i know the doctors really performed a
miracle and the breast reduction hurt
like hell
but i'd like to thank all the guest
hosts who did a great job while i was
gone i imagined they had nothing but
nice things to say about me do not
adjust your television screen
greg did not get more ridiculously good
looking
i'm sitting in a normal chair not one of
the small ones custom crafted to fit
craig's abnormally childlike frame we
also had the stage crew remove the sippy
cup because i don't spill
or be like president biden without cue
cards or gut fill without a booster seat
it's a book that no one is buying like
the plus by greg gutfeld it's the least
popular tour since gut gutfeld joined
the chippendales their bail was set at
zero dollars which is the same value as
greg's autograph
nice penmanship
[Laughter]
sure the ratings plunged it was an
embarrassing disaster and we ended up
having to let go all of them
but at least they talked headset out of
doing the whole show shirtless
and boy did i miss you guys
what i didn't miss was the news
nothing calms your senses like a total
news blackout
it beats an alcoholic blackout right jb
yeah
i don't know what he's talking about
neither do i why should you you're
wasted in fact i realize when you don't
look at the news it's like one of those
eye exams it only matters if you're told
to look at it
and when there's no news you find the
best replacement is hysteria from those
miserable wretches take democratic
colorado's secretary of state jenna
griswold who told the guardian that if
republicans win
the country could lose the right to vote
in less than three months
yes
that's not insane
so did she tell the guardian the
newspaper or her own personal legal
guardian who keeps her from eating her
own hair
because that's the news when there isn't
any you reach for the unhinged stars
our democracy has been put in peril and
there are not just there's there's
several
crimes here
that
could have been committed including
obstruction if any member of the
intelligence agency had taken this
this many documents out they would be in
jail my top level expert legal analysis
of the affidavit is
why ain't this dude in jail president
sticky fingers already stole classified
documents top secret documents
see i love him
mainly because he looks like my my dad's
shaving brush
[Laughter]
that's a compliment
but on crazy cable to maintain eyeballs
you've got to get even crazier eli
mistle there seen him
seen there impersonating a dandelion
he has cracked the code of cable
television say the most absurd thing and
it never has to come true because no one
is keeping score
it's not news it's simply stuffing coins
into the twitter slot machine hoping for
a payoff except no matter how dumb your
ideas are they never you never have to
pay for it because it's like taking out
a student loan
because just like the family photos on
my desk it's not real
and you notice that when something real
comes along like this the widely
respected statistician nate silver
claims liberal public health elites
pressurized pfizer to delay fast-track
approval of its coven 19 vaccine well
until after the 2020 election
thus denying trump a win before voters
headed to the polls
yeah calling them public health elites
is like calling a tapeworm a weight loss
consultant
now whatever you think about the
vaccines okay we're talking about people
who believe that the vaccines worked yet
still wanted them from the public
so who's worse than hitler come again
that means they were ready to sacrifice
lives to keep trump trump from looking
good
yet they wanted to call him a killer
as if that's not the pot calling the
kettle justin trudeau
[Laughter]
look silver's no trump fan but he points
out that trump's action likely saved
hundreds of thousands of lives and a
delay would have killed tons yet those
people's names would still have probably
ended up on the dems voting rolls
because the dead people
but again if you believe trump is hitler
then what's a few thousand deaths to
keep him from killing millions even
though trump kept us away from wars the
way joe keeps us away from complete
sentences
maybe it's unproven but you're talking
about the same people who suppress the
laptop story in order to win an election
so why wouldn't they do that here
meanwhile they keep squeezing the
remaining drops of juice from the
mar-a-lago raid like it's a florida
orange
those are the most unimpressive
documents since the first draft of
killmeade's new book
what happened to those nuclear codes
anyway maybe they're under the bed where
the p tape got filmed right
by the way that's the most action jimmy
fallon saw in years
[Laughter]
that was a needless crack but videos of
a cracked out hunter and his hookers
playing hide the hard drive
no story there at least until months or
years after the election
then you get the confession from a
battery-powered popsicle named mark
zuckerberg
about something we knew all along so you
see my point amplify fake stories and
bury real ones like their former clinton
associates
yeah she killed him
or rather amplify stories that are easy
to speculate on like documents or
russian disinformation or cat's marriage
and avoid ones with real ugly facts but
i know that when i'm on vacation what
passes for news has no effect on me
unless i'm in mexico and the news is
about a cartel member leaving a human
head next to the waffle maker at the
hotel's continental breakfast i really
don't care
i also know that when journalists go on
vacation so does the news it's like they
both own a timeshare together in boca
so in the absence of facts we went from
nuclear codes to documents to
indictments
indictments the media loves this word
assuming you don't know what it means
but you guys watching me right now do
and that's why the media hates you so
much
someone once said you could indict a ham
sandwich
and i bet it probably wasn't brian
stelter
he'd keep on tampering with a defendant
so fake news rules in real news is
redefined as hateful speech is there a
crime wave yes but don't talk about it
bring up a soros-funded d.a well you're
anti-semitic if you point out that it's
young black kids knocking out other
black kids and older people well that's
racist too if a citizen on twitter calls
a children's hospital and catches them
admitting wrongdoing against young
patients well it's the citizen who's
guilty a person gets banned from twitter
for doing what people used to call
journalism
so what's left is an array of bottomless
what ifs which are perfect for hackneyed
drama queens on cable the stuff that's
ignored are palpably real and they
affect you inflation crime corruption me
being the new king of late night
hold your plots
hold your applause
oh that was
that was gratuitous
i need a shower after that
i actually do i stink
but real stuff in life journalists don't
have time for that it used to be the dog
days of august when producers would do
anything to plug a hole even asking
amateurs to host for me
tune in to one nation saturday at eight
o'clock at eleven o'clock well i'll be
talking to uh someone will be commercial
yeah can i finish please charlie yes
thank you very much
well
am i not enough
apparently not
i'm so tired of having to do charity for
this guy
it's like sponsoring a child from
overseas but this one commutes from long
island
[Laughter]
you know fake news is year round it's
the profit model so what to do with the
media hacks i say turn them off pack
their bags and send them on a one-way
trip to somewhere
they can't even tweet from tell the
ladies of the view to pack extra moo
moos because they won't be coming back
soon
maybe when they're on permanent vacation
the rest of us can finally get some
peace
[Applause]
she keeps her wine where she keeps her
children inside a cardboard box
okay cops needs anchor julie banderas
he's our favorite brewer this side of
anheuser-busch the comedian behind the
new youtube special somebody had to say
it jim brewer
she's one hemingway you'll never find in
cuba
editor-in-chief of the federalist molly
hemingway
[Applause]
and his name says undercover stripper
and his outfit says undercover yacht
captain
co-host of the clay travis and bucks
extend show buck sexton
julie what i always like about you as a
news anchor you never tried to get
people to trust you no no no
no no no no no no no you first of all
you always want to undersell right and
under deliver right that's my motto in
life you know like just you know set the
expectations low and that way if you
actually get something right people are
like holy crap she is credible yes
but it is funny how like they use the
same phrases they use the same vocal
inflections with stories and they have
no memory of everything they said before
which is like if true or he's going to
jail what is it do you are you obligated
to have amnesia in order to do the news
absolutely yeah no i mean you just have
to tell the news as if you actually
believe it and right and most of the
time it's unbelievable so you just got
to fake it yeah that's where that's i
think where trump came out with fake
news yeah because a lot of the people in
the uh media industry are faking it yeah
until they make it but a lot of them
aren't really making it no they fake it
till they make it then they get fired
yeah by the way i'm trying to get brian
selter on the show oh that doubts right
oh i'm sure we'd love to come on yeah i
think you've been so kind i think i'm
fat shaming him into getting a peloton
bike oh jesus so
isn't that really what it's all about
jim where do you stand on this you're
you're not in the beltway you're not in
the news thing i mean do you do you feel
like whenever you turn the news you're
getting fed a lot
there is honestly i don't
anything they say
i know is a complete opposite right
whatever's going on i know this is
full-blown nitrogenous waste at the end
of the day so no i don't buy any news
whatsoever so no except for fox news of
course because we here deliver nothing
but the truth yes yes of course
of course well you live in florida yeah
it's the best you live in florida right
i live in naples florida yes
yeah
home of the uh pastel color pants can
you can we have can the press ever
regain trust from people like you say it
again can the press media ever regain
trust no no
zero that's done they've lied through
their teeth and you back to uh the trump
you can hate trump all you want he's the
first human being that came out just
fake news fake news fake news fake news
and yes and for centuries that has been
a century in three years a tree went
yeah
and it's worldwide even it's been
australia going hey man this stuff is
hey this is ridiculous
is that australian or new zealand i was
somewhere in between yeah yeah but i
liked it anyway i was strangely aroused
i don't know molly do you find it weird
like when you go away on vacation you
come back and nothing like whenever i go
away nothing big happens so i'm assuming
it's all about me i feel exactly the
opposite like you could take two days
off you come back and it's like you're
in a completely different country major
things have happened i happen to take
like my one day of vacation the day of
the mar-a-lago raid you know came back
at midnight i was like now what now what
happened here oh dear i have really
chosen the wrong day to take off um but
the media are so
bad at these things and particularly
with that mar-a-lago raid story i've
been finding it funny how people are
acting like we didn't just go through
the fbi you know uh
faking evidence to go after the trump
campaign doing all sorts of horrible
things like wiretapping and putting
confidential human informants on it and
now they're acting like this is just a
brand new day that never happened they
never ran the russia collusion hoax
right you hear people saying like well
we just don't know what we don't know
i am so sick of hearing that i heard
that for years during the russia
collusion hoax i don't want to hear it
anymore i just don't
it's pretty funny because it's like
this back suppression story if true
it would be huge it's as big as the
hunter biden thing but why didn't it go
anywhere i mean it's nate silver that's
why i was away when that that i thought
oh this thing's going to explode i wish
i was at work but then it just kind of
petered away they put away and then they
started doing more stuff about the the
raid instead it's like when something's
happening they go bigger on the other
side i if i could just say i did write a
book called rigged about the 2020
election i actually told this story in
the book it's not even really under
debate you know pfizer came out after
the election announced that they had in
october gotten everything they needed to
do in order to get the vaccine approved
and it was clear you know people were
openly saying that they had to delay
this announcement until after the
election and yeah i mean there were so
many things that were done that were
improper to affect that election and i
remember reading that in your book
it's a fantastic book rigged
and you can still get it
it's available it is yeah it is in most
bookstores and on amazon much like your
jacket
what professor did you roll i should
have a qr code here just so everybody
knows where they can where they can get
it did you just get married or something
engage engage
employees thank you fox news yes
so
you know i never thought that you and
judge jeanine would hit it off
but
yeah the judge is a lot of fun i was
actually putting out the parties like
that
she's super fun
i don't want to be that we would have a
hell of a time
she doesn't drink by the way you know
that right you're freaking kidding me no
she doesn't
what about the zuckerberg stuff did that
get i was away zuckerberg goes on joe
rogan says this incredible thing and
then like the bat the news was busy
trying to put up the fbi response the
lying is the point everyone needs to
understand this now this isn't uh this
isn't a surprise this isn't oh my gosh
how could they have gotten this so wrong
when you have elements within the fbi
which we were calling the deep state for
for years that come forward and talk
about election misinformation i
guarantee you there was not a single
misinformation tidbit that would have
hurt the binding administration it's
always republican misinformation in some
capacity i mean fouchy
i think people had to get through their
heads that fauci was just the health
deep state in a sense a bureaucrat of
many decades and it was a mistake for
trump to keep him on i think we all know
that now trump has been very honest
about some of his personnel decisions
that could have been different from what
they were but the purpose of cnn the new
york times all these other institutions
is to be battling propaganda machines
for the left they're not the the 50 i
worked for some of them by the way
they're 51 or whatever it was that
signed that they're actually not so
stupid that they thought the laptop was
misinformation they lent their
credibility or rather lit their
credibility on fire purposefully to give
cover to the shutdown of the story so
that relatively uh you know low
information folks could say oh well i
guess if the smart cia people said what
it was not a lot of smart people we have
to bring we have to do a hearing and do
as dana says 52 days of hearings just
interview each person that signed that
letter right by the way i just got a
promotion by the way that's how it works
i want to apologize for hurting you with
the ladies by saying you were engaged
because i know that's like you're
probably not going to be dating as much
i mean your name is buck sexton i mean
who
who's monogamous with that name
[Laughter]
what's funny is your poor name is like
jerry's jerry slavin's peel
because it's the opposite
i'm an idiot you need more blue
we need more blue-collar journalists
people who didn't go to college that's
what we need that's the solution right
thanks vic
i invited my plumber over
ugh